let charge B decide the function so we
are what are we going to talk about
today so we are going to talk about
function
calling the reason I wanted to do this
topic because I feel like this is one of
the most
underutilized tool for de uh for
developers uh who are using open right
and the topics that we will be covering
are what is function calling first of
all models that support it we will also
see chart completion structure
structure uh we will see the flow how
you get it working and uh the demo so
how to make it work you can poke it with
a
stick I'm just kidding it's h like what
is function calling so it's an API call
for function to Output adjacent object
containing arguments so what basically
means that if you have a list of
function uh the model the GPT model can
decide which function function to run
according to the query and uh and the
second part is it you can describe the
uh type and the structure of the
argument that you are getting from the
chat
completion what that means basically is
function calling doesn't give you answer
directly function calling gives you the
argument that you will need as a input
in your defined function so the flow
looks like this chat completion give you
a j object which has all this different
information like role which is assistant
the content the function call and the
arguments so arguments you extract it
and then you give it as a input to your
function we will see uh the structure of
these in very details uh okay so the
three major parts of chat completion the
model the message and the
functions so model that support function
called
sgp4 I mostly use GPT 3.5 turbo it
basically works well uh for for my for
my use cases uh what are messages so
whenever you use chat completion right
there is a section of Ro defining role
and then the content and if the role is
the system that means you are deciding
the nature of the assistant mostly it is
like act as a helpful assistant but it
can also be used to pro uh to prevent
hallucination like you can write do not
give any answer uh if you do not have uh
you know do not assume anything or uh
from your side if you do not have the
information so the system basically the
role system basically defines the nature
of the assistant uh if the role you give
is the user then it acts uh the content
act as a query so you give role user
content then query if the role is
assistant that basically the response
from the chat completion so basically if
you have role user you are inputting it
to the chat completion if you have a
role assistant that is acting as a
output or response of the chart
completion now going to the structure as
I as I uh
already uh discussed there are three
major parts the model uh the message and
the function so we already discuss
message here the role is user that means
this content is your query the function
the function also have a very uh like a
defined structure to it right the
function should have a name uh you can
give any name right you you have to
describe it what this function is doing
so for example I'm trying to find the uh
a fun I'm trying to write a function
that gives me the uh key of the lowest
value or the closest Resturant uh to me
so I'll write uh the Des in the
description find the list value uh and
the parameters are basically what is the
output what whatever the roles and
assistant we saw before in the chart
completion output this is what defines
us so location will be the name of the
argument and the description I
highlighted this description in you know
because I feel like this is the most vow
factor of uh function calling because
you can Define the type you want to
receive the argument in so it is easy
for you to feed it in your function so I
want my description as a list of all the
restant and distance as a dictionary
restaurant name and its
distance the third is required uh
distance and the most important part
again is a function call so there are
three modes of function call Auto you
can Define which function to uh Auto
basically means the model is selecting
the function uh uh and then there's a
this uh this mode where you define this
function to run always and there's a
nonone mode where you will say like yeah
none of not this function so
this is the overall structure uh I hope
uh everyone like gets the structure uh
and now for the demo uh we have like a
three parts where we will uh write a
call function calling and what it see
what is its output we will also add more
function and like a list of function and
see if it selects the function in which
function intelligently and we will also
use a wonderful Vector database to
connect it the function with
r
so let's get into the
demo uh okay any do we have any question
meanwhile it will be a
good time to throw the
questions okay
so let's get into the demo
part for the demo I have uh made a fake
kind of data that I live at a place
where the pizza has at a 20 uh 20 M KFC
is at 10 and kitchen is at 15 and I will
just uh you know uh I will just try to
find if it outputs KFC because this is
the minimum distance uh to
uh so this is our function uh my
dictionary minimum key we basically want
to find the minimum key of the minimum
value so we are doing function calling
for this input right so we will have to
we will have to describe the function in
a way it outputs uh for which is fit for
this function right so tools is
basically a list of function and I'm
talking about this particular function
so as I told you in the structure there
should be a name get measure description
get the list distance parameters
properties properties uh name is
location so whenever we will get
argument we will get it in the name of
location uh type and description list of
all restaurant and distance as
dictionary restaurant name and its
distance okay uh now the messages part
we saw a Content measure the least
distance with given restaurant and and
have attached the restaurant list and
this restaurant list needs to be
formatted in this way so I have done
that part here uh and don't worry about
the notebook it will be available after
the stock so if this uh so as I told you
the role of the system so this is BAS
basically defining the nature of our
assistant don't make assumption and uh
what value to try to plug into function
ask for clarification right and this
part if the role is the user part then
the content become your query so this is
basically my query where I'm asking it
to measure the list distance with given
restaurant and I'm also providing a
restaurant list now we have given chat
completion the message messages which
are appended to each other and the tools
and the tools has to function already
there's a get current weather and there
is a get measure so let's see if it you
know it it decides the get measure
function first of all so when we print
the output of assistant
message see uh we Define role assistant
that means it is a response now the
function it decided is get measure so
voila it decided get measure not get
weather current weather and it also
given us the location which I told you
this part this portion will be the
basically name of the arguments that we
were getting so all we have to do now is
to extract this particular thing uh and
how do we extract it well we get into uh
the tool calls which basically this get
the first list get the function here and
then get the argument here
now what we have is a
dictionary with the restaurant name and
its distance the same thing that we
defined over here I want a list of all
the restaurant and distance as a
dictionary of restaurant name and its
distance so we are aligned to the
description right and now when I feed it
into my dictionary the data it gives us
KFC is the nearest because according to
the data as well that I had given the
kfcu was the
nearest
so okay what if we change the content
what we change the query I'm in glasow
and then we see that it changes the
function now the function is get current
weather and it also gives location it
gives us uh whatever argument we need
you can get more creative and start
adding you know Vector databases one of
the best Vector databases I know is
quadrant and uh you can also have like a
ask uh you can have like
a uh query like you know when you give
uh data to database you can ask what are
you can even give biomedical data so if
I ask what are the symptoms of malaria
and if it is present in the database it
kind of gives you the name of the
function you have to run is r and the
argument is the query directly so uh
this this will basically go into the r
function or R
pipeline so uh the pipeline has been
done the demo is also done and I hope
this talk was useful for you uh you can
find me on LinkedIn Twitter and the
notebook will be available at uh son
panash 95 P data 2023
so uh I would like to take questions if
there
are good morning everyone I have only
one question yes if I
use if I use a a sh a to like sh can
I can of make a company like a f company
with parameters with scro team with a
complete team of programmers can I do
with ch on CH thank
you uh if you have to make a company uh
is that you asking
uh oh juice a v company juice for juice
for Deb if I want to Da my own app my
own web enti web app I can can I use so
I got your question uh now so there's
this new tool called autogen which or
orchestrate all the conversation you can
really use that if you want like you
know uh if you want a whole control over
different functions as a com as uh
something like if you want a product
manager and the software and you want
them to communicate the best way is
autogen right
now yes thank you thank you
thank you thank you uh will the
recording be available could you share
the GitHub again yes my GitHub is son
pankush
85 and the notebook will be in pi data
2023 thank you so much everyone like it
was really nice interacting with you
today